welcome to the reason live stream which
today is pre-recorded for scheduling
purposes I am Zach Weissmuller joined by
my colleague Nick Gillespie hey Nick
hello from the past and our guest today
is Clark Neely a constitutional lawyer
and uh Vice senior vice president for
legal studies at the Cato Institute
thank you for joining us Clark
great to be here thanks
today we're talking about the indictment
of Donald Trump on 37 criminal counts of
mishandling classified documents and
obstructing the investigation into that
mishandling we'll briefly sift through
the details of the indictment and the
specific charges and then talk more
broadly about the political implications
and how those of us who are interested
in shrinking the size and scope of
government should think about what
transpired here
um Clark in a tweet thread referencing
the movie Tombstone you described this
indictment as a bombshell and a magnum
opus what is so epic about this 49-page
document
well I think there are a few things
um first the the the quality of the
allegations in terms of the level of
detail
um and the uh the the source of the
information
um we don't have to guess whether uh doj
has the goods so to speak I've written
hundreds
dozens if not hundreds of complaints in
my career and I've read plenty of others
sometimes you get the sense from a
document like that that the person who
wrote it has a sense of what may have
happened um but maybe they don't have
all the evidence yet and they're kind of
you know uh probing away in in the dark
this is the opposite of that
um you get the very clear impression
from reading this indictment that the
federal uh prosecutors uh know exactly
who did what and at what time and and
with whom and not only do they know it
they're going to be able to prove it uh
from at least three different highly
credible sources uh one is an audio
recording that Trump seems to have made
when he was uh speaking with
um a Ghostwriter and a producer at the
Bedminster Golf Club where he says in
effect that uh he shows them a document
that he knows to be highly classified he
says he could have Declassified it when
he was president but he didn't and now
he doesn't have the power anymore which
completely destroys what seemed to have
been his sort of primary defense before
they all uh the the prosecutors also
appear to have video evidence
um from mar-a Lago from the security
system there of various staff members
moving boxes around including at a time
when they were under a grand jury
subpoena and in effect hiding those
boxes so that they can't be reviewed in
response to that grand jury subpoena and
then also uh the they're almost
certainly going to have the testimony of
multiple Trump lawyers and staffers who
were he essentially appears to have
attempted to recruit into a conspiracy
uh to
um to hide documents and to only make a
partial response to the grand jury
subpoena that's a lot of really
difficult evidence to run away from as
I've said elsewhere a recording almost
always beats a Serial liar in court and
so the conduct is detailed it's
devastating and doj uh is almost
certainly going to be able to prove it
in court now could Trump have some kind
of mitigating evidence or exculpatory
evidence I suppose he could
um I'm not holding my breath
uh could you just very quickly explain
what what are the limits of uh lawyer
client privilege and all of this kind of
stuff because that's part of the gotcha
here seems to be that like his lawyers
are tripping over themselves to be like
yeah you know what he really did
everything that you think he did
right yeah so so there is a a lower
client privilege uh that that is robust
and um can be asserted to prevent the
disclosure
um of of communications between a lawyer
and client and and even to prevent a
lawyer from from having to to even talk
about those at all but there's an
exception it's called the crime fraud
exception and so if the client tries to
involve the lawyer in uh some sort of a
crime
um you know for example you know if I
have a lawyer and I say hey I'm going to
need you to pick me up right in front of
this Bank uh on a certain day at a
certain time and maybe there'll be a lot
of police there and if I come running
out with a gun in my hand I still need
you to to drive us away that's um that's
not going to be protected by return to
client privilege and that's the argument
here is that that's what Trump tried to
do with his lawyers is to involve them
in a conspiracy and it's already uh
judge Merrell Howell here in Washington
DC is is already required at least one
of his lawyers
um to to testify about Communications
that the lawyer had with Trump under the
crime fraud exception I think that's
going to stand up let's look at the some
details of the in dive in here pulling
it up right now the first 31 counts
counts 1 through 31 are willful for
Violet for willful retention of National
Defense information so that's actually
holding on to the documents the
remaining charges are basically some
form of obstruction or lying to
investigators it says that without
authorization he retained at mar-a
Mar-A-Lago documents relating to
National Defense uh and here are some of
the types of documents there's a sick in
his office he had six top secret
documents which is the highest level of
classification uh supposed to be for
documents that uh you know are present
would present a grave threat to National
Security if they were exposed we can
talk a little bit more about
classification and what shouldn't and
shouldn't should and shouldn't be
classified in a minute but just going
through the numbers here then in the
storage room he had 11 top secret 36
secret 28 confidential documents
according to the indictment uh just some
examples I have highlighted of the types
of documents
um uh an intelligence briefing related
to uh military activities and planning
of foreign countries another one
concerning nuclear capabilities of a
foreign country
um so you know this is fairly high level
stuff and then this is these are some
pictures that have floated around the
internet uh of how these documents were
being stored on a kind of stage in
Mar-A-Lago there's a bunch crammed into
a bathroom
and then there's a bunch of newspapers
clippings mixed in with redacted
documents on the floor
so not not a lot of care being taken and
and that the interesting thing about me
or about this picture to me is that it
shows the degree to which it was like a
bunch of his personal stuff just mixed
together with classified documents kind
of opening the door for then the FBI to
come in and sift through all of this
stuff to look for classified documents
you know you get me one hoarder on that
jury and Trump is going to walk yeah
so so uh
and all of this uh is happening under
all of these charges are happening under
the
uh Espionage Act Right so uh and we as
Libertarians earlier on the uh you know
reason Roundtable this week there was a
lot of discussion about you know should
the Espionage Act even be a law at all
um but putting putting that aside for a
second you know what uh do these
pictures and this evidence say to you
Clark about the kind of strength of the
case against Trump
well um it's horrifying it's horrifying
so two things are true uh we do have a
problem with over classification no
serious person disputes that but that
doesn't mean that every document that
has been classified
um was improperly classified uh when I
clerk for a judge here in Washington DC
in the mid 90s
um there was a case involving terrorism
that was in that judge's court so my
code clerk Bob Levy and I both had to
get top secret SCI especially
compartmented information clearances
that's a really sobering process and it
culminates in a meeting um in a secure
room inside the Department of Justice
where uh it's explained to you what the
handling procedures uh will be and the
consequences if you fail to
observe those procedures they do not
mess around uh with that level of
classification and for good reason there
are plenty of governments uh you know
that the the US government plenty of
documents that the US government
produces the disclosure of which would
would result in the loss of of human
lives it would result in people being
killed who are working for our
intelligence agents agencies in hostile
countries it would result in being
people being killed because of military
operation That was supposed to be secret
was not so um we should this is not open
to discussion there are documents that
that not only have to not be turned over
directly
um to agents of a foreign power they
have to not be stored in an insecure
location because uh foreign powers are
aggressively working
um to to penetrate uh any facility where
they think there might be useful
intelligence and you could absolutely
bet that includes Mar-A-Lago so the the
careless handling of these documents
um is inexcusable we don't know at least
we in the public don't know uh whether
uh discernible damage was already done
from the sloppy handling of these
documents but it's a it's something you
don't mess around with
um or if you're a responsible person I
should say you don't mess around with it
obviously Trump did
um and um you know so so I just we can
talk about whether other people should
have been prosecuted or prosecuted more
aggressively for their sloppy Document
Handling practices and they probably
should have been but to Simply wave your
hands at this and say well you know
everybody does it and therefore Trump
should get a free pass I think is
untenable
for the Espionage aspect of that the
criticism that a lot of Libertarians and
civil Libertarians have of that law in
particular the Espionage Act of 1917
World War era law World War One era law
is that it it has a real chilling effect
on uh whistleblowers for instance that's
how it's been used uh kind of in modern
times against people like Daniel
Ellsberg Edward Snowden it's being hung
over the head of Julian Assange right
now
um and who and Julian Assange you know
not even a government employee he's a a
publisher and so that opens up questions
about like if you're a journalist
publishing classified documents are you
then uh potentially subject to this law
so
um I think there's some serious concerns
about the Espionage Act that that should
be taken seriously and this is something
that I would ultimately like to see
repealed in in the long or short run
um on the other hand I I see her and
acknowledge your point Clark that
some level of classification seems
completely necessary and valid for you
know like legitimate State secrets so is
there a way uh when you know now now
that we're we're talking about all these
issues of classification and the
Espionage Act that we could more
sensibly
think about classification so that that
people who should not be tripping over
these kind of laws keep getting you know
entrapped in them
right now I think those concerns are
absolutely valid and and there's no
question that the Espionage Act and
other uh similar laws have been abused
uh by the government in order to cover
up things that they would rather uh the
public not know about
um even when there's no sort of
legitimate kind of operational or
security reason for doing that and um
the part of the challenge here of course
is that
um this is an area where public scrutiny
is difficult because there are some
things that that you know members of the
public just can't know
um because of the sensitivity of of that
information you know some new technique
that we have for example for collecting
information or the fact that we have or
have not managed to penetrate a
particular foreign government
um these are things that ordinary
members of the public just cannot know
um or else again you know lives could be
uh at risk or or people could die and
and Incredibly important operations
could just be uh torpedoed uh through
the disclosure of this information so
it's a challenge right because we just
don't have the ability to to have the
kind of public oversight that we know is
generally required to you know bring the
disinfecting power of sunlight now the
other hand
um there's a huge problem which is that
we're talking about the exercise of
Power by government officials
um you know in the dark and I can
guarantee you man there are there are
prosecutors when the Department of
Justice that if you made them into a
crossing a school crossing guard
tomorrow they would figure out a way to
abuse the amount of power they had as a
crossing guard so it's a very difficult
and challenging and I would say I think
we almost have to resign ourselves to
the fact that there's no we're not going
to find any kind of perfect equilibrium
here but we can certainly do better and
we should do better well and it's also
worth pointing well here a question for
you Clark uh do you have any sense of
out of the you know what percentage of
documents that are actually classified
top secret
really don't deserve that because over
classification you know this is one of
the greatest bloated you know government
programs over the past 30 years or so
um you know because when you step
outside of the partisanship of this and
oh is this you know is this bad for
Trump or good for the Democrats or
something like that it doesn't really
put you know people at risk uh you know
overseas agents people in the military
and stuff like that
um you know it it is kind of
mind-boggling to think okay so there are
these top secret documents that have
been hanging out in Trump's you know
toilet for months
um we don't know what they are does the
government know what they are and are
they like yeah you know what what we're
going to send a group down there and
they're going to go get them eventually
et cetera you know if you know we are
entering this moment ha after Decades of
losing trust and confidence for good
reason in the way the government talks
about stuff you know is this ultimately
is this very serious
oh there's no actual information that's
there yes absolutely I mean we we don't
know but it has been
for example that some of the uh FBI
agents and doj prosecutors who were
themselves
um
members of the National Security Squad
were not sufficiently cleared to to see
some of the documents that They seized
and had to go and get additional
clearances
um in order to handle those documents
and that's you know again yes we have a
problem with over classification and an
answer to your question nobody could
possibly know how many top secret
documents uh should should have been
classified at a lower level surely there
are some but reasonable people can
differ about how many but I take
seriously the the representations that
have been made that some of these
documents were so sensitive that even
members of of you know the sort of the
National Security division of the
Department of Justice who have very high
clearances were not clear to see some of
the documents and I'll add one more
thing this is something that hasn't
gotten widely reported but is is I think
somewhat ominous and that is that
there's a discrepancy
between the documents that are listed in
the in the FBI's receipt in terms of
what it what it finally managed to get
when it executed the search warrant at
Mar-A-Lago um in August of last year and
what documents have been charged in the
indictment that came down last week it's
about 13 top secret documents that show
up on the uh the FBI's uh uh you know
that are generically described in in the
return from the search warrant that are
not a charged in the indictment and one
speculation and let's emphasize that it
is Justice speculation is that those
documents are so sensitive that the
originating agency whichever agency it
was that produced them could have been
the CIA the National Security Agency the
national reconnaissance office nro
said to the justice department that that
those documents were so sensitive that
we can't even risk the possibility they
could ever get out in the public and we
do not authorize you to include them in
that indictment
um because they just can never see the
light of day I'm not saying I know that
happened but it has been speculated that
that there are documents in the mix that
are at that level of sensitivity so
again
no I was just going to say it sounds
like that might be why the UFO story is
uh getting spiked as we speak yeah go
ahead Jack oh yeah let me uh let's go
through the second
a component to this which are the
obstruction charges which in a way are
really the reason this is happening
because as we'll get into others have
taken home classified documents with
them but because they cooperated more or
less in some cases more than others the
the FBI and the justice department has
has gone easy on them but Trump uh has
been accused of doing everything he
could to hold on to the boxes and you
know our colleague CJ chairmilla's like
theory for this is the my boxes theory
that uh he just believed these are my
boxes I'm entitled to them my boxes
hands off but we can dig a little bit
into his motivations but first let's
understand what exactly
is a LED he's alleged to have done
um this is Count 32 conspiracy to
obstruct Justice uh it names Donald
Trump and his kind of body man walty
NATA that who know are accused of
knowingly conspiring or confederating to
conceal a record document or other
object from an official proceeding
uh there are some of these conversations
uh that are recorded that this kind of
validates the my boxes Theory somewhat I
don't want anybody looking I don't want
anybody looking through my boxes uh what
happens if we don't respond at all these
are all statements Trump allegedly made
wouldn't it be better if we just told
them we don't have anything here uh and
then here's a conversation between Trump
and a staffer and I guess this is where
the ghost writer is present and they're
looking through one of these boxes there
is there are allegedly classified
materials in there Trump uh is trying to
decide you know can I can I not show
this guy or girl my document I don't
know he says I think we can probably
write the staffer says yeah we'll have
to try to and then trump interjects
declassify it and then he says see as
president I could have Declassified it
now I can't you know but this is still a
secret so that indicates Trump was well
aware that he this was classified
material and it also kind of gets to a
weird thing where
so much of this case seems like it might
hinge on you know did keep Declassified
like that's his that's his defense so
far it seems like his I as president
Declassified all this stuff and I have
that power
um that is kind of weird that like could
he technically while he was still in
office have just kind of announced I
hereby declassify all of these documents
and then this would not be an issue
whatsoever
yes strangers that may seem the
president does have that power president
has the power to declassify documents or
also to um in effect Grant security
clearances and show classified documents
to whomever he wants and he's you know
he's a commander-in-chief he's a chief
executive he has those Powers
um what has not really been worked out
or you know kind of litigated is is
whether there's some sort of a procedure
that would need to be
um you know invoked in order to validly
do that um just doesn't really come up
and um so we don't know but again that
exchange that you put up on the screen
just a moment ago where he uh says
um in a recording uh to an ordinary
citizen who doesn't apparently hold any
security clearance you know that this is
a very sensitive document I'm not
supposed to show it to you I could have
Declassified it but I didn't and now I
don't have the power I mean it's pretty
damning
um and I I don't know how you walk that
back I suppose you know Trump being
Trump he'll say something like well you
know that was literally the only
document in my possession that I didn't
Declassified he classified all the other
ones I I don't know
um you know I think I was let me add
this
um
one gets the impression that that you
know Trump kind of came up through a
certain
culture and it was a culture of the New
York real estate market of the of the
1980s and I get the impression that that
Trump sort of sees the world as kind of
a big game um it's a game it's a contest
and only Chumps follow the rules because
you know in the New York real estate
market you don't follow the rules you
bribe government officials you take
advantage you rip people off Etc and um
and that's how you win and I really kind
of get the feeling that that's how he
has approached the whole rest of his
life including his political career that
essentially you know rules and Norms are
for Chumps and it's all about winning
and so you know if you get caught for
example uh uh you know possessing some
documents that you're really not
supposed to then that's a new game and
the game is how do you get out of it the
way you get out of it is you
you enlist your staff in helping you
figure out you know where do we need to
hide the boxes Which documents need to
get shredded so they never get found and
so I find it completely plausible that
he did that in response to the grand
jury subpoena and I'll add one more
thing as a you know career lawyer and
somebody who's clerk for the federal
Judiciary man if you want to make
absolutely certain that the doj decides
to nail your skin to the wall jerk them
around in the course of an investigation
lie to FBI agents or and or prosecutors
while they're investigating the case and
see what happens can I as somebody who
was both born in New York City and is
you know phoning in from here or
um I I agree with you uh you know what I
see when I see that is not necessarily
anything specific to New York or real
estate but rather it's a CEO who runs an
organization like a petty fiefdom or a
grand fiefdom at that point but also and
I think this is really important because
this gets to not only the question about
Trump's Behavior but also I think a
Sinking Feeling among an increasing
number of Americans what you're
describing is politics particularly in
DC and everything that has come out of
you know Washington realistically over
the past 50 years but out of
presidencies and you can you can look at
people like uh you know Bill Clinton and
the way that he acted behind the scenes
George Bush in plain view and the way
that we you know got into things like
the Iraq war or the way we paid for the
War uh the way that Dick Cheney talked
about how you know we don't need Norms
we can just basically do whatever we
want we have a theory of the presidency
that allows us to do this uh we're going
to be talking about Edward Snowden a
little bit but you know when Barack
Obama was saying you know we have the
most transparent Administration ever and
then when Snowden reveals the fact that
you're a liar about that you know Obama
isn't like oh yeah you caught me he's
like oh you know we should have a
conversation about you know ubiquitous a
surveillance so that this is really
important I think to take it out of
partisanship and it doesn't you know
mean any of that but we are we're in the
fourth Act of five acts maybe maybe it's
a four act play of the degradation of
the way that the government works and in
plain view and this is both the blessing
and the curse I think of the era of
force transparency that most came into
focus with Wikileaks and this you know
the stuff that Chelsea Manning let
leaped and the things that um Julian
Assange did and he has you know he has
sacrificed his life effectively for
revealing the way the government does
business which is very much at odds with
the idea that there are rules and that
the people involved in this system are
the ones who are maintaining the rules
when nobody's looking you know they're
the equivalent of medieval craftsmen who
you know put full faces on gargoyles
that were you know in the eaves of Notre
Dame and you know that nobody would ever
see they are so dedicated to process and
we know that that's horseshit
um and it is terrifying to see Donald
Trump act like that but I think it's
also important to recognize that we got
a bigger problem here and it's not
simply Donald Trump
yeah I think with uh go ahead sorry so I
think with characteristic perspicacity
and they can really put your your finger
on on the The Heart Of The Matter uh an
image occurred to me earlier today that
you know if you've ever been white water
rafting
um that your guide will kind of try to
scout the river and what they're looking
for is is sort of what the currents are
doing and where they should be on the
river and you can tell a lot about
what's underneath the surface of a river
by by what you can see on the surface in
terms of you know boils of water and
Swirls and things I think that's really
a good metaphor for what's happening
here
um there's so much energy going on
beneath the surface and I think the
energy boils down to this and I I
tweeted about it this morning
um we are told that no one is above the
law in this country and that is
aspirational and completely false if
you're a sufficiently high-ranking
politician you are absolutely Above the
Law practically speaking and we we don't
we've never really had a kind of a an
explicit conversation about well just
how far above the law like if Donald
Trump beat somebody to death on the
front you know lawn of the of the White
House while he was President would he
have gotten a free pass for that
probably not
um but but do politicians routinely get
free passes for for messing around uh
with classified documents and and
showing them to people who who don't
have a clearance yeah absolutely they do
so there are two questions we've never
really had an explicit discussion about
is just how far above the law are
high-ranking politicians and I think
that's a function frankly of your you
know your status in the organization and
under what circumstances can your free
pass uh be revoked and I I see Trump in
some ways as essentially kind of The Oaf
at a cotillion you know he's this
awkward guy that doesn't know the
rhythms of DC politics and and he comes
you know blundering in you know he's
gotta he's got his invitation but he's
dressed wrong he doesn't speak right
um he's drinking out of his flask and
he's embarrassing everybody
um because you know there's a way that
you're supposed to take advantage of
that free pass and it's the way that the
clintons do it you you lie in a certain
way you you push the envelope in some
ways but not otherwise other ways and
then when you get caught you hire the
right lawyers you hire the white shoe
lawyers who used to work at the
Department of Justice and they still
have relationships there so they can
pick up the phone and say you know you
really don't want to prosecute Hillary
um just in general and also because she
might be president one day so let's work
this out Trump just doesn't know how to
speak that language he doesn't know how
to move in the in that milieu and I
think that's one of the reasons why
there's so much uh uh you know more you
know Sturm and drag over this that he's
it's not so much what he did although
that's part of it but a lot of it is
that the way he went about it he's
embarrassed The Establishment by you
know taking advantage of his free pass
and not doing it in the according to the
the customary Norms if that makes sense
so do you think that is an more an
argument for revoking that free pass
from everyone and saying well moving
forward
presidents are not going to be so far
above the law or is it kind of the
opposite where we say look
Trump could have Declassified this he
could have waved the magic wand and this
wouldn't have been a problem at all so
let's just recognize the political
reality that presidents are kind of
Above the Law and that all has to be
resolved at The Ballot Box and through
the political process
yeah you know I think there's just not
one answer right so so certainly
um you know more even-handed treatment
um would be important I mean in my
opinion Hillary Clinton not only uh
violated the the laws about uh
mishandling classified documents or
National Intelligence information is the
technical term but I think she also
obstructed Justice I think for example
um destroying you know applying that
beach Blitz or bleach bit or whatever it
was to her server while some of those
documents were under subpoena but again
you know she did it in a particular way
right she had the right kind of lawyers
are representing her and and so
um
um the so that's one point I think that
more even-handed treatment
um is is vitally important but also and
I think this is going to be maybe even
more difficult is dialing back some of
these laws and we've talked about
already how the Espionage has overbroad
in some ways and so are many other
countless other federal laws and so
um you know if we're going to give a
political high-ranking political
officials a free pass for violating
certain laws then that suggests that
perhaps those laws shouldn't be on the
books at all and we'd be better off if
we just dialed all that back whether
that's even feasible in other words you
know I've been doing Criminal Justice
Reform for a long time and what I see is
essentially a ratchet here I'm not
saying that you could never repeal a
criminal law but it is extraordinarily
uh unusual and these laws tend to be
very very sticky and so I think the the
essentially the the giving out of free
passes to people whose job almost not
requires but you know it invites them to
to violate some of these laws is just
the accommodation that we've reached
that we've got these overbought laws on
the books they're virtually impossible
to repeal but we've got people in
positions of power where they kind of
you know they're probably going to
commit some violations I mean good luck
running by the way for federal office
without committing some kind of a
violation of campaign Finance laws I
don't think it can be done so we created
a situation where a certain amount of
free passes have to be handed out just
to make sure that the machine continues
to operate if there's a path out of that
ass I don't see it yeah I hope we can
get to that I just want to throw you
know one more kind of Log on the Fire
here and again there's a partisan
version of this but also just a
structural one which is you know it's
it's kind of laughable when the FBI says
uh you know somebody was obstructing an
investigation in every article I would
Hazard you know since reason was founded
in 1968 we would we would be arguing
that of course you obstructed Justice
because that is how the FBI operates the
minute you talk to them they have
figured out a way to get you on perjury
or obstruction of justice or doing
something I mean that's ultimately what
Martha Stewart was found guilty of for
God's sake you know and and that took
the form of her defending her companies
when you know she was being attacked in
the press for insider trading which she
was never charged with nor convicted of
but so we have an organization and it's
not you know it's not like the FBI oh
you know they were bad back in Jag or
Hoover's day you know during the third
FDR her Administration it's like we had
a report that came out I you know what
like a couple months ago that damned the
FBI and the way that the chief you know
investigative Organization for federal
crimes within Washington Etc you know is
an absolute either it's a joke or it's
incompetent or it's overreaching
constantly and all the time and
shielding certain people and screwing
over other people so you know this thing
is uh you know it it's I I don't know
what the right metaphor is but it's like
every aspect of this operation shines a
light on a different part of the
government which is thickly and and
deeply corrupt not and and I don't take
any pleasure in that because I do think
like you know the nihilism that is
becoming evident uh in America because
we don't for good reasons trust or
partic you know our our political and
even our business institutions
um you know that way Madness lies that's
that's becoming a low trust Society
where nothing gets done but so you know
listen I agree with everything that you
said and I would throw one more Log on
the Fire which is to say um which is now
an inferno yes no unfortunately right
um that you know I yield to no one in my
willingness to throw rocks at the FBI
but but it's not just the FBI the FBI is
a component of the Department of Justice
the Department of Justice itself is
rotten to the core and rotten to the top
on this front and what I mean by that is
that um uh the the Department of Justice
routinely hands out free passes uh to
members of the Department of Justice
when they engage in criminal activity
I'll just give you a few examples really
quickly
um Rachel Rollins uh who was a
progressive prosecutor up in Boston and
then was appointed as the U.S attorney
for Massachusetts was
um recently uh pressure to resign and
ultimately will resign or did resign for
engaging in some of the most um
breathtaking Hatch Act violations that
have ever been documented essentially
what that means is engaging in politics
while you are holding a political office
in fact what she did was she tried to
help her preferred candidate get elected
into the position that she had left when
she became a federal prosecutor and this
included for example sharing non-public
Department of Justice information uh
with her preferred candidate and um and
and you know information derogatory to
to her unpreferred candidate and when
they investigated when they looked into
this she serially lied uh to
representatives of the office of
Inspector General which is a crime
um and instead of being prosecuted like
any of us would have been she was
allowed to Simply resign from that job
um and and this is not an isolated
incident they had a mid-level manager at
the doj a few years ago who was
investigated for sexual harassment and
that investigation determined not only
that he harassed serially harassed
employees but he did committed at least
one sexual assault and they determined
that he had been
um that his interview had lacked Candor
which is doj's way of saying that he
lied when you are a doj person they let
him off the hook as well and finally you
may recall the two thousand and uh I
believe 12 prosecution of Senator Ted
Stevens from Alaska the dog team doj
prosecutors in that case cheated their
way through that case it only came to
light because of a whistleblower uh and
not one of them received any meaningful
uh not only not punishment but any any
meaningful career consequences so doj is
an organization that is just absolutely
rotten when it comes to keeping its own
house in order and holding its own
members to the same standard as the rest
of us and the FBI as a component of the
Department of Justice um I would say
reflects uh that cultural uh milieu that
cultural mindset of of of lack of
accountability and double standards
so there was a tweet uh put out by uh
Edward Snowden that kind of bolsters the
or agrees largely with the point I think
you're making Clark uh Edward Snowden
someone who knows a little something
about the Espionage Act uh says uh it's
not wrong to say that the indictment of
Donald Trump for mishandling classified
documents is a case of selective
prosecution spilled secrets are very
much the currency of Washington and
Trump was not alone in splashing them
around he was just the least graceful so
that's kind of in accordance with the
you know he's the ogre at the cocktail
party or whatever that's that's
embarrassing everybody
um and you know when he's talking about
spilled Secrets being the currency of
Washington we saw a lot of classified
information leaking out during the Trump
Administration Comey even uh leaked out
some documents that were technically
classified uh and was reprimanded by the
uh the Inspector General but never
charged and then what we've kind of been
circling around a little bit and what
everyone brings up as an analogy is
Hillary Clinton is what Hillary Hillary
Clinton did the same or worse or not as
bad as what Trump did let's take a quick
look back at what Comey had to say at
that famous press conference where he uh
dropped the charges and then dig into
that question a little bit more deeply
although we did not find clear evidence
that secretary Clinton or her colleagues
intended to violate laws governing the
handling of classified information there
is evidence that they were extremely
careless in their handling of very
sensitive highly classified information
for example
seven email chains concern matters that
were classified at the top secret
special Access program at the time they
were sent and received none of these
emails should have been on any kind of
unclassified system
but their presence is especially
concerning because all of these emails
were housed on unclassified personal
servers not even supported by full-time
security staff
although there is evidence of potential
violations of the statutes regarding the
handling of classified information
our judgment is that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring such a case
all the cases prosecuted involved some
combination of clearly intentional and
willful mishandling of classified
information or vast quantities of
information
exposed in such a way as to support an
inference of intentional misconduct or
indications of disloyalty to the United
States or efforts to obstruct Justice we
do not see those things here
so the the obvious rejoinder here would
be that you know he mentions obstruction
of justice is one of the components that
he judged was not present in the Hillary
Clinton case you mentioned earlier the
kind of acid wash of her servers
that could be certainly interpreted as
some obstruction of justice but what do
you think more generally about the
Clinton Trump comparison should she have
been handed a free pass
or you know should Trump because she was
kind of handed a free pass also be
handed a free pass
well let's be clear what Hillary did was
jaw-droppingly irresponsible and
criminal
um if you are housing if you are the
Secretary of State and you are housing
emails on an unsecured Betty Crocker
Easy Bake server at your home which she
was you might as well set up every email
that comes into that server to forward
to Putin and Xi Jinping and Kim Jong-un
because they're going to be reading them
uh and um so so the level of
irresponsibility and cynicism on her
part and criminality uh is difficult uh
to express now she is a high-ranking
politician and she you know everybody
knew she would be a candidate for office
and and presumably you know thought that
she would be president and so according
to the Norms of Washington DC she had to
be let off the hook and everything you
just saw from Comey there is a is a you
know sort of a retcon or a retroactive
attempt to rationalize the pre-ordained
conclusion that Hillary Clinton would be
let off the hook and that was
preordained so then the question is well
why doesn't Trump get the same
consideration
um and you know I mean look there's a
there's a tweet a former uh federal
judge Michael ludic
um uh had a tweet on on Twitter where he
said you know if if Donald Trump at any
time during the back and forth uh with
the National Archives
um
organization that have been asking him
to give back the the boxes had just done
it then he wouldn't have been prosecuted
I think that's almost certainly right
but it's I'm not sure if judge lewd
really understands kind of what he's
just acknowledged which is that some
pigs are in fact more equal than other
pigs because the rest of us certainly
would have been prosecuted there's an
Air Force Lieutenant Colonel who just
had maybe a few dozen uh classified
documents you know in a storage pod and
in his personal quarters who just got
three years in federal prison for that
so we know for a fact that if it had
been anybody else we would have been
prosecuted but again you know if you're
a sufficiently high-ranking politician
you're going to get a free pass the
question I think is
um you know was Trump's uh alleged and
I'm I'm confident that he did it but you
know whatever right it plays out
um uh Shenanigans with with the attempt
to obstruct Justice lying to the FBI and
so forth um was that sort of materially
sufficiently worse than what Clinton did
where you know she went about
obstructing justice in a way that's
that's sort of more in keeping with DC
norms again hiring the right Law Firm
having your lawyers do some of the dirty
work instead of you Trump just went
right to the source and said okay well
let's just you know grand jury wants
these documents I don't want to give it
to him let's have a conspiracy to make
sure that they don't get them
um I'm not right I don't feel like I'm
in a position to to really have an
intelligent opinion about whether Donald
Trump's Behavior was or wasn't worse
than Hillary Clinton's I will say this
he was stupider Hillary knew that she
was in the circle of you know of of
trust so to speak in that Circle of
special treatment
um and that she could get away with it
Donald Trump should have known
absolutely that whether it's fair or
unfair he was no longer in the circle uh
you know of trust and he no longer had
uh the kind of all-access free pass that
the clintons possess which uh do you
think and this might be beyond your uh
pay grade or expertise but hell you know
why not ask it which one do you which
behavior set of behaviors do you think
poses more of an actual threat to
National Security
because you know his head uh you know
when uh Hillary Clinton you know uh
hired Geek Squad or something like that
to come and put in her personal server
right you know and everything from
Chelsea you know uh uh confirmation
pictures to whatever was going on in the
state department nothing important I'm
sure it was passing through that Trump
hiding you know his redacted documents
among fake covers of Time Magazine you
know where he's he's listed as men of
the year or something like that in the
toilet
um you know there's no doubt like I'm
sure North Korea is prowling you know
North Korean agents are prowling
Mar-A-Lago they're dressed up as illegal
Mexicans who are working there you know
without visas and without the proper
documentation But ultimately you know
which do you which of these examples you
think is actually worse for National
Security
I I think it's impossible to say because
we don't know exactly what was on
Hillary's server versus what was in
Trump's uh boxes I think
um in terms of which one sets a worse
example for others to emulate is
definitely Hillary uh the idea of just
you know having all official email go
through an unsecured server in your home
um is is you know just it's hard to
imagine a more irresponsible uh uh you
know sort of uh course of of conduct to
set
um a couple things we don't know is you
know did people who would otherwise have
been sending or did people who would be
sending Hillary Clinton sensitive emails
when she was Secretary of State pick up
on the fact that they were going to a
private server and maybe maybe they they
hand delivered some things that they
would otherwise have emailed if you were
on a secure government server maybe they
use oblique language
um or you know otherwise try to to sort
of you know mitigate uh the exposure of
that information knowing that a it was
going on to a private server and B you
certainly can't take that up with
Hillary
um and and try to get her to stop uh
using that uh private server now the
other thing we don't know is what
exactly uh were in these boxes that that
you know we don't even know how many
boxes of this plan is probably close to
100 boxes one thing I don't even know is
like did Trump curate this information
or were the people just running around
the the Oval Office just stuffing stuff
into boxes and so whatever was in there
was by happenstance my guess is some of
each but there are certainly things that
if if Trump had gone out of his way for
example to really curate like the
um you know the the attack plan on Iran
that was supposedly the document that he
waved about in front of these uh
uncleared uh people up in New Jersey
it's difficult to imagine a worse
document to be out in the open
um and so I don't know really depends on
the mix of information on the Hillary
server versus in the Trump bathroom you
know given the uh the merger of the
Saudi Arabia and Liv uh you know golf uh
concern and PGA uh you know which and
they were having events at uh Bedminster
at Trump's uh Golf Course in New Jersey
who knows maybe you know uh shake or two
is like hey I got to take a leak I'm
just going to go wander around a little
bit and you know well you know speaking
of Bedminster Trump had some thoughts
from Bedminster yesterday uh on the
indictments so let's get the Trump
version of events now and react to do
that
this is called election interference and
yet another attempt to rig and steal a
presidential election
more importantly it's a political
persecution like something straight out
of a fascist or a communist Nation
don't forget this persecution is being
done by the same weaponized agencies
that for seven years have been running
illegal psychological warfare campaigns
against the American people from the
russia-russia Russia hoax
to the no collusion Mueller Witch Hunt
to impeachment hoax number one
impeachment hoax number two the fake
dossier
paid for by the Democrats how about the
fake dossier remember that one the FBI
Twitter files and so much more
so so I mean that that's an example of
that it's just the the frustration of
kind of pulling apart a trump speech
where there are certain components there
that are valid like you know aspects of
the Russian investigation as we've
covered on the stream before were pretty
bogus and a lot of ways we're completely
bogus yes and and uh yeah you know we
dissected the Durham Report with Eli
Lake a few weeks ago and you know I'm
I'm uh almost I'm getting to the like
it's time to just dismantle the FBI uh
position uh but we we can talk about
what to do about the FBI in a minute but
then it's also mixed in there with you
know every single impeachment which I
think is you know definitely debatable
uh he I I think he he did engage in
impeachable Behavior especially in the
the Ukraine situation but but the I
guess my question of that is like the
fact that the FBI and the justice
department as we've already talked about
have been sloppy at times seemingly
politicized or unfair seems to have
opened up
the opportunity for this kind of
obfuscation from somebody like Trump and
I don't know if you have any thoughts as
to
how we move forward from this this spot
because it's one thing to say you know
we gotta stop handing out the free
passes but then how do you do that in a
way where
you're not just
acknowledging the political reality and
seeing that you're going to inflame you
know a large segment of the country over
this perceived unfairness
yeah I look uh it's a tall order I mean
you know the Department of Justice is an
utterly rotten and compromised agency uh
I know I've been throwing a lot of stink
on them but look I mean this is this is
the agency that gave Jeffrey Epstein a
slap on the wrist they caught the most
prolific child molester in the history
of this country and gave him a slap on
the wrist um and the plea agreement that
they reached with him the the
non-prosecution agreement is one of the
most corrupt documents that I have ever
seen in my life
um and and they handed that out you know
uh why because well he just knows a
bunch of famous people and some of them
were on his plane to uh
his private island so so can you redeem
an agency like that I'm not sure
um my friend Scott Thompson who was
former Chief of the Camden County Police
Department
um which was understood to be one of the
most uh corrupt uh police departments in
the country
um he was he was promoted to Chief and
what he did was he fired everybody and
then made everybody reapply for their
jobs he only took the ones that he had
confidence on and he turned that Police
Department around for being one of the
most corrupt in the country to being one
of the most laudable and and um
honorable and and respectable
departments in the country is that
possible with the FBI and the Department
of Justice could you fire everybody at
in effect fire everybody in both of
those organizations and force people to
reapply for their jobs no you could not
would it require that level
um you know uh you know an effort of
that magnitude in order to sufficiently
clean house yeah it probably would so
there's a thing you could do and it
probably cannot be done
I think it's uh worth adding watching
you know Trump you go through his list
of uh you know grievances his Festivus
lists there for a minute he's absolutely
right about all of that and of course
it's larded in with a bunch of [__]
and things like that I'm looking at that
and the one thing I want to say uh Zach
and uh Clark is you know what at least
we can say Libertarians are not to blame
for this Libertarians routinely get
blamed for you know moral breakdown
because you know people smoke weed now
instead of drinking themselves at to
cirrhosis uh you know where we don't
care about kids we don't do this or
we're irrelevant blah blah blah but it's
like the one thing that is good to say
is that a Libertarian perspective on the
the size scope and spending of
government the role of it and whatnot
you would not lead to this kind of
outcome where you have two equal and
opposite forces uh you know that that
command fewer and fewer adherence from
the American population of Republicans
and Democrats these are are two parties
that have been around since the before
the Civil War and they are locked you
know like uh Professor Moriarty and
Sherlock Holmes in a death Embrace
constantly falling over reichenbach's
Falls and neither of them can get to
that place that I think Clark is talking
about where you say you know what in the
interest of the country in the interest
of something other than the most base
and banal and vulgar self-interest that
I need to win the next news cycle or the
next election I'm actually going to do
the right thing and start to reform a
government you know that has single
digit ratings and increasing aspects of
it you know Congress you know however
much we hate the president you know
Congress is lucky when it gets out of it
gets into double digits and approval
ratings and it's because of this
self-interested self-dealing where it's
like the other person does worse where
if you think I'm bad wait until the next
person gets elected that is you know in
in a way I think we might be able to use
this indictment drama and I you know I
think I think Trump is is guilty I think
he's wrong the way he acted is wrong and
that should be changed but what we need
to take away from this as a way to
actually create a different system and a
different framework that does not just
say you know what uh you know it it puts
the American electorate in the uh in the
role of you know of little kids watching
their parents beat each other uh there
are no cops that are coming like this we
need to we need to be removed from this
kind of spectacle and put into a
different situation altogether or create
that situation
the
the the pro like the prob one of the
problems is how to get there because
right now we s it seems to be that it
seems like we're caught in a vicious
cycle to some degree and this you see
this in it's a dialectic with no
possibility of synthesis exactly and you
see this in countries that have high
levels of corruption where all if all
the top officials are constantly either
breaking the law or at least kind of
pushing the the boundaries of legal
Behavior then their political opponents
come in and they kind of with some
justification
take them down legally and then it flips
back the other way and we're you know
we've seen it the pendulum kind of
already swinging back and forth from
Clinton to Trump and now in the Republic
in the just yesterday the Republicans in
the Senate have announced that they're
you know uh they have these documents uh
that may or may not prove that Biden was
involved with uh Ukraine and some sort
of bribery scheme and so you can see
this back and forth pendulum swing uh in
motion and what you know I'd like to see
Libertarians somehow disrupt that uh but
I I'm not sure you know what what the
next steps are in order to stop that
that pendulum swing can we run the uh
Vivek ramaswamy clip he has an idea
January 20th 2025. if I'm elected the
next U.S president
to Pardon Donald J Trump for these
offenses in this federal case and I have
challenged I have demanded that every
other candidate in this race either
signed this commitment to Pardon on
January 20th 2025 or else to explain why
they are not
so yep pardons have obviously played a
role in presidential crimes in the past
what role do you think they will play if
any in this situation
well this is this is uh now we're really
in the uh uh
out beyond what anybody can predict here
um in the Twilight Zone so there are two
possibilities besides uh I would say
that you know vivec pardoning a
president is outside the realm of
possibility since he won't be president
but
um but I I would not rule out the
possibility that Biden pardons Trump I
don't think it's likely maybe it's
something on the order one in ten or one
in 20 uh but you could imagine Biden
essentially treating this as an act of
statesmanship the way Nixon uh Ford did
with Nixon
um and then there will be the subtext
right because everybody knows that uh
the the preferred candidate uh for the
Democrats in the next election is Trump
they want Trump to to run and if they
thought that you know this would enable
him to stay in the in the you know in
the race and get the nomination
um you could see that sort of checking a
couple of boxes for them again I don't
think it's likely but I think I wouldn't
rule it out the other uh even more sort
of uh science fiction question is um
could Trump pardon himself if it were to
somehow be elected
um you know if he's not yet been
convicted by the time and you know he he
gets to be elected president and
inaugurated if that were to happen he
could just order the Department of
Justice to terminate the investigation
but if he had been convicted but somehow
still manages to to win the presidency
then the question is can he pardon
himself and guess what we don't know the
answer to that question thank goodness
it's never come up in real life uh but
having kind of poured over the relevant
language uh just the other day I think
it's within the realm of possibility uh
and not a completely Preposterous
reading of the relevant constitutional
language and you know I I don't even
know what's going to happen if we get to
that point I mean I I just think we're
gonna we'll be tapping these the the
Strategic cynicism reserves of the
entire country at that point so
hopefully it won't come to that and to
uh clarify if Trump is under indictment
or is even found guilty there is no
reason to believe that would mean he
can't run for president
no no there's no disability
um running for president or holding the
office
um there are some crimes and there's a
provision the 14th amendment that says
you know if you've committed a rebellion
against the United States or treason
right um then you can be ineligible but
even that there's a loophole there
because it says you're ineligible for
any office under the United States and
one argument is that the president is
not under the United States the
president is at the apex of the United
States and not subject to that language
so I don't think there's any short of
being uh impeached and removed from
office uh if he manages to win the
election I don't think there's any legal
mechanism for preventing Trump from from
both either running or uh for or holding
office as As a matter of kind of
historical analysis you know uh Gerald
Ford you mentioned and you know it's
always widely been you know questioned
did he agree you know as a condition of
becoming Nixon's Vice President that he
agree to Pardon him uh if if you know
that uh became necessary or not but
beyond that uh Gerald Ford you know
famously pardon Nixon and said our long
National nightmare is over uh which was
this idea of having you know a president
who might might be uh you know a
criminal at the highest level of trying
to you know kind of run a secret
government did do you think that Ford's
pardon of Nixon had that effect of
ending a national nightmare you know on
balance did it help us get to the next
stage or was it actually the type of bad
um you know papering over of something
without actually dealing with the root
causes it you know it kind of like
scabbed over an infection that was going
to erupt later
what a great question I'm not enough of
a historian to know I was very young at
the time and I don't really have any
contemporaneous Recollections so you
know what makes me the first thing that
popped into my head you know was the
stimulus payments uh after the 2008
downturn some people think that saved
the economy some people think that it uh
was unnecessary uh and simply propped up
a rotten banking system and set the
stage for the inflation that we have now
I don't know the answer to that either
of my gut I suppose tells me that um it
would be easy to minimize uh the the
magnitude of of what was happening at
the time when when when Ford was
presented with this question of whether
to pardon Nixon and to sort of project
backwards that that we would have made
it through if he hadn't done it I think
the best of all possible worlds he would
be if he hadn't done it had not
established this Norm of essentially
giving presidents who commit serious
crimes on office of free pass
um but it's also possible that that the
alternative would have been worse I just
don't know
can we uh look at the Spiro Agnew clip
uh Zach because that's this is another
variation on this theme of like we you
know and and I think it's it's
attractive on some level like this is a
dark moment and a dangerous moment we
need to figure out a way to get past it
um one of the uh things that is funny
about this clip which was uh Rachel
Maddow talking to Lawrence O'Donnell on
MSNBC kind of just skylarking or you
know floating a trial balloon of a way
where hey maybe we can get around this
and if you know you know we will you
know that's all in ironic quotes and
stuff but let's watch this clip and then
discuss it
with Spiro Agnew you get a 40 pound 40
count Federal indictment that is brought
against him not related to Watergate but
because of crimes that he was committing
in his own office in the white house
um and in that case with the justice
department
um bravely and and nimbly and
controversially brokered with him is
that that indictment would essentially
go poof in exchange for him agreeing to
get out of the White House and so that
that delicate balance between needing a
political solution to the criminal in
the White House and needing a criminal
solution and criminal law solution to
the criminal in the White House is one
that 50 years ago this year in 1973 we
dealt with uh in 1972 we dealt with with
Spiro Agnew you have to wonder if the
justice department is considering
whether there is some political solution
to this criminal problem whether part of
the issue here is not just that Trump
has committed crimes but that Trump has
committed crimes and plans on being back
in the White House do they consider as
part of a potential plea offer something
that would prescribe him proscribe him
from from running for office again I
don't know I would imagine if anything
like that happened that it would have to
come from the defense side of the
negotiation that the that the Trump team
would would say oh by the way and with
this we will also you know drop out of
the uh the race for president otherwise
it would put the justice department in
this position that Donald Trump claims
they're in you know he claims they're
trying to stop him simply try to stop
him from becoming president again and
that's the only reason uh they're doing
this
and uh I'll just uh to give a quick uh
recap of people uh Spira Agnew was
Richard Nixon's laughable vice president
of former governor of Maryland who it
was found out uh you know after he was
the vice president that he had been
taking bribes as governor of Maryland
which he continued while vice president
uh he was a Greek American he was
famously the you know the first Big
Greek politician and uh perhaps most
memorably his name is a palindrome for
grow a penis but he left office which is
one of the reasons why Gerald Ford was
in the mix to become vice president who
effectively uh uh pardoned Nixon but
what do you think of that because people
you know one of the things that is
happening now and I think rightly and
certainly Donald Trump says this is that
we're entering a Banana Republic phase
where you know each successive president
can threaten you know their their
predecessor with you know being put in
jail well or having all kinds of
conditions put on their continued
citizenship and whatnot you have now you
know people on MSNBC particularly people
like Rachel Maddow were saying you know
the problem with Trump is that he is the
destroyer of norms he's going you know
he he you know has his steak cooked well
and he eats it with ketchup he's like a
horrible human being he's an oaf an ogre
a bull in a china shop Etc but there you
have people like that actually floating
an idea where if you read about this in
Chile after Pinochet you would be like
what the [__] is going on here this is
the you know the quintessence of like a
Banana Republic and it's being talked
about seriously on you know major media
excuse me we um we just we haven't had a
conversation we haven't had an explicit
conversation about the nature of the
free pass that that high-ranking
politicians are going to get they're
definitely going to get some kind of a
free pass we haven't really had a candid
discussion about you know sort of what
it looks like we just know that they get
one and so that leaves a room for
somebody like Trump to say well wait a
minute you know Hillary Clinton is you
know a corrupt criminal flaunter of
norms
um who put you know National Security at
significant Risk by you know setting up
this Betty Crocker server in her house
like what why am I getting prosecuted
that's not a completely unreasonable
position to take now
part of what I think would come up if we
had this very you know sort of unseemly
discussion about you know why
high-ranking politicians get a free pass
that the rest of us don't and what the
shape of that pass is
um is for example Hillary I don't think
Hillary Clinton is any less corrupt than
Donald Trump is she might even be more
corrupt but I think she's less dangerous
I think she's less irresponsible I think
she sort of understands institutional
norms and the importance of things like
um you know uh
cozying up not cozying up to dictators
like uh Kim Jong-un so so in some sense
you could make a case that she should
get a bigger and more durable free pass
than Donald Trump
um and and you wouldn't be crazy but
like can you imagine I can't imagine
ever having that discussion explicitly
and so this heuristic you know this this
um formula is just out there somewhere
in The Ether we've never really tried to
work it through or or or concretize it
and yet it's there and the the sort of
seeming inexplicability of why Hillary
Clinton gets a free pass but Donald
Trump doesn't get a free pass is going
to be a source of conflict and grievance
because we can't have an honest
discussion about who gets free passes
and why
are there any you know structural or
institutional reforms that would help
with this problem I mean we had your
call your Cato colleague Ian Vasquez on
here a while ago talking about the
decline in human Freedom around the
world uh particularly post pandemic and
a lot of that has to do with
institutional Decline and Rise in
corruption uh specifically here in the
United States are there is there
anything you know that that's where I
think you know Libertarians tend to
bring a stronger analysis is looking at
the institutions and the structures
um is there anything there that could
help
stop this slide towards the Banana
Republic if that's how we're putting it
or is this really ultimately a political
problem
uh so the answer can it be saved because
you know can we redeem the institutions
I don't know but yes there is something
that can be done and Nick kind of
alluded to it earlier
put a a fire in the belly libertarian
in charge of the Department of Justice
and give them you know in effect uh a
free uh you know give them full
authority to enforce all the laws
against whoever breaks them
um and uh you will see a a rapid change
in behavior
um because you know if I for example uh
were that attorney general um I would
create a whole new unit within the
Department of Justice to make sure that
we have completely revoked the free
passes uh that high-ranking politicians
currently uh enjoy and make sure that
they understand that those free passes
have been revoked um and that they
themselves will receive at least as much
attention from the Department of Justice
as for example uh inner city uh drug
dealers have them receiving
um and you know for however long I don't
know how long it would be before that
attorney general will be impeached
probably a matter of uh weeks instead of
months but uh I think we're talking
minutes but yeah hopefully hopefully
they get weeks yeah but you know I I
sort of fantasize about the idea of
maybe you know bringing a um a Jason
Voorhees hockey mask into the office on
the first day of the the job the way
that you know Elon Musk brought a
whatever it was a toilet just to convey
to the kitchen sink kitchen right yeah
uh yeah it must be later used as a
toilet I'm sure so so you know I'm being
a little bit flippant but I do think
that if if it were possible uh to to
have uh you know the the the Attorney
General of the United States not be a
member of either tribe neither team blue
nor team red uh but somebody who is not
does not have that political affiliation
and has a commitment uh to even-handedly
enforcing the law not just you know sort
of saying that which they all understand
they're supposed to say it but actually
doing it
um and revoking the kinds of free passes
that we saw handed out to uh Hillary
Clinton
um and um uh arguably Mike Pence and at
least so far Hunter Biden and just
saying look I don't care I don't care
who what what office you hold or who
you're related to
um you're going to be held to the same
standard as the rest as the as all the
Muggles out there
um you know I think that would be
progress it might burn the whole thing
down uh but at least it would I think
sort of Lance the boil of this you know
this this
um cynicism this this uh you know anger
and frustration that people have that
it's only people on my team who are
getting singled out for bad treatment
not people on the other team that's not
true
but you're not crazy if you have that
impression yeah and I I want to stress
that of you know that you know a lot of
people are you know now or not a lot of
people people in the commentarian are
like oh Americans are too cynical
they're nihilistic Etc we have every
reason to be we have been incredibly
patient and diligent you know in hoping
for the best you know over the entire
time I'm turning 60 in August my entire
life conscious years from you know
starting in the uh you know in the early
70s through uh the current moment it has
been an unrelieved landscape of
government lying to you and then saying
yeah we got it we got it we're going to
fix it and then lying some more you know
and whether it was Watergate uh you know
first Vietnam then Watergate then the
church commission uh talking about how
the NSA and the CIA and the FBI were
just you know uh surveilling everybody
regardless of the law okay that's good
Iran Contra it goes on and on and on and
finally with uh between Chelsea Manning
and people like Edward Snowden and even
you know people like reality winner uh
and whatnot we have been fed lies we
give politicians every opportunity to
act well and they don't so we are right
to be you know chastened by this and to
be uh very cynical I guess a question uh
for you guys that I have um you know as
libertarian so you're already skeptical
of government power but you're not you
know you are idealists as well you're
not like hardcore cynics and you're not
looking for a way to to work the scam to
your own Advantage is there a
generational component to this and you
know the one thing that is good is that
you know gerontocracy is looking worse
and worse with every passing year that
80 year olds keep holding power and
exercising more and more power is there
anything on you know in the millennial
or gen Z generational kind of cast of
characters that is rising that gives you
hope that the Next Generation which is
starting to ascend into positions of
power in terms of political power
economic power cultural power are they
working from a different script or have
they learned the lesson of the past 50
years which is that you know do unto
others then split kind of applied to
politics
oh
Zach do you want to sure yeah I guess as
the uh the Elder Millennial on on the
show I'll I'll say that I think that
um you know Millennial politics I think
were largely and I'll just speaking for
myself here shaped by the Post 9 11
experience and that engendered a lot of
skepticism of the National Security
State and
um kind of overseas commitments and
to that regard you know you know Trump
was kind of a new sort of candidate he's
you know he's a he's a boomer but he you
know called out the mistakes of the Iraq
War on stage in South Carolina
uh in front of the GOP audience uh and
so if but then if you look at you know
younger the younger generation whether
they're on the right or the left they
also tend to be in that mold more
skeptical of intervention there's also a
skepticism of you know I think Wall
Street uh given that we you know we're
going out into the job market during the
finance the First Financial collapse uh
so I think that is the that those are
some of the defining features of like
the that next generation of uh
politicians on on the left and right and
perhaps that skepticism could be
leverage to you know restrain power My
worry is that it is going that some of
the ire and some of that energy is just
going to be harnessed to go after the
wrong targets whether on the left that
is you know demonizing
um actually left and populist left and
right kind of demonizing uh corporations
now rather than the you know State
Machinery that is the real problem
sounds right to me I I
um I guess I would add one more thing
that gives me sort of a a sort of a an
unsettling sense of optimism which is
that the two major political parties
seem to be engaged in a contest to see
which one can destroy their brand first
um they're both taking a wrecking ball
to the edifice uh of of you know sort of
their own political power
um by by just demonstrating over and
over and over again why they don't Merit
the trust confidence or support of
anybody
um and competing with one another to
sort of be the most uh Preposterous
caricature of themselves that they can
and so to the extent they're successful
and I'm talking about the Democratic
Party in the Republican party of
actually uh uh self-sabotaging and
burning to the ground uh the edifice
that they have constructed over the last
however you know many generations
um then that could open up some space
for uh new um uh alliances and and new
organizations of power that wouldn't
have been possible
um you know before it's almost the uh
the extension extension of the dinosaurs
may enable a new ecological niche for
the unaffiliated mammals of the
political uh life and and do I know
that's going to happen no but it
certainly seems as if we could be headed
in that direction which which I think is
is a silver lining for the culture wars
that we see unfolding today yeah I I
hope you guys are right I mean what
worries me is that and obviously Matt
Welch and I wrote a book about the
decline in belief in or even
identification with the Republican and
Democratic parties the Declaration of
Independence a decade ago
um you know it's kind of like so Ford
and GM you know built shittier and
shittier cars uh you know and by the 70s
they had to compete against you know new
new brands that were coming in from
overseas that were smaller lighter
better at what you know at getting
people around it you know safely and at
a good price point it's almost as if
they were in the 1970s and Ford and GM
are still putting out you know the pinto
and the Vega but they've managed to
completely protect themselves from any
Imports um it seems so hard in the
political arena for that third term
whether it's the libertarian party and
you know whatever they're up to or the
green party or anything else like the
ability for new entrants to seriously
enter the marketplace of politics seems
you know very difficult but more to the
point and Zach I you know I I think
we're going a little bit off scripture
but I'm curious if you know are the
younger kind of rising members of
Congress and I don't know that they'll
be around for the Long Haul but you take
somebody like a Marjory Taylor green on
the one hand who seems to have she's
grown up in a world of failed government
and conspiracies and she just wants to
control it to her own weird ends on the
one hand from a kind of conservative
right-wing position and then you have
people like AOC Alexander Casio Cortez
who is like we can get the right people
in place and shove our version of the
good life down everybody's throat
um you know in the economy in the
culture uh you know in foreign policy
whatever that means and I want I worry
that J generational change is not enough
I mean it's coming whether you know
Boomers like me like it or not it is
absolutely coming but it might not be
sufficient to uh to actually change
things it might just make it you know
people with with more Vitality doing
this oh I definitely agree that it's not
sufficient uh it what it what needs to
happen is that someone you know
harnessed the energy and focus it on the
right problems
um the these structural problems that
we're talking about whether it's
corruption in government
or uh you know just uh out of control
police powers that are completely
unaccountable
um these are there there's to this point
there has not been that kind of
transformative figure or Beacon who you
know you know clear articulates that on
on the political stage at least
um you know maybe that type of figure
will emerge at some point but yeah I
agree it there it's you know a change in
the demographics is not going to be
enough it's got to be a change in the
vision
um and hopefully it happens before the
slide uh is to go too deep yeah where I
mean we're starting to look more I could
bring it back to Banana republics we're
looking more and more like Venezuela or
Cuba where you know you meet the same
boss or meet the new boss a little bit
younger but pretty much like the old
boss right these regimes keep going
Clark can I ask you uh uh and uh what
would it take to get you to leave uh you
know Cato and become the uh independent
Attorney General of the uh of the United
States
is it is it free parking is it uh you
know is it a better vacation policy
I think it would just be a matter of
leave of absence for however long was
necessary for me to appear at my
confirmation hearing which I would hope
would be kind of a Pay-Per-View event
because let me tell you it would be
funny it would be fun and funny
um for probably about 20 minutes until
the big Shepherd's crook came out and I
got pulled off the chair um there's not
the slightest possibility that I could
be confirmed any uh uh you know position
like that at this point but the
confirmation hearing would be a barrel
of glass can I ask you you cast a kind
of dark shadow on Criminal Justice
Reform which is something that the
libertarian movement more broadly I know
reason in its very early issues was
talking about how the fact that we are
over policed in terms of there are just
too many laws covering too many
activities that should not be illegal
Cato has been doing that for decades you
you yourself you kind of were arguing or
hinting that there really isn't much
progress being made or
um you know or that can be made is is it
really that uh dark or is you know is
that kind of an overstatement aren't we
in a better place even if our politics
are kind of a shambles and things like
that are we in a better place in terms
of the number of people who are being
subjected either to the carceral state
or just the kind of uh judicial legal
surveillance state
no I don't think we're in a better place
um some of the numbers look better uh
but the culture of uh American criminal
justice is um uh just absolutely
horrifying in the sense that
um you may remember this famous quote uh
where uh laverenty Baria who is Stalin's
chief of secret police said to Stalin
you show me the man and I will show you
the crime um we absolutely have that now
we have a plea driven system of mass
adjudication where we have really
basically a point and convict approach
uh to criminal adjudication because of
the high tolerance for natively coercive
plea bargaining uh that the Judiciary
tolerates and that prosecutors Embrace
uh and so
um the only real limit on on the
government's ability to uh you know put
people in prison is is kind of a
combination of resources
um and I would say some you know high
level kind of political sense that some
people you know can can go in at some
Camp you know if you're if you're
selling drugs at the dormitories at
Harvard you're probably pretty safe but
not if you're on the streets of
Baltimore so no I don't think we're
better off unfortunately I think it's a
very um I've written a piece that I say
that our criminal justice system is
rotten to the core I believe that to be
true it has three basic pathologies over
criminalization uh plea driven Mass
adjudication and near zero
accountability for members of law
enforcement and no system that features
all three of those pathologies I think
merits the trust confidence and support
of people now it can be redeemed what
you have to do is this you have to stop
treating those pathologies as the
metaphorical equivalent of a bad case of
the flu or perhaps pneumonia and
prescribing things like Advil uh and and
antibiotics uh metaphorically you have
to trade you have to face it and treat
it for what it is which is a an
incredibly aggressive metastasizing
cancer uh that can only be treated with
a very aggressive of course of of
chemotherapy and other you know fairly
toxic uh therapies but if you try
anything less then you will fail and
that's basically why we haven't made
meaningful progress on Criminal Justice
Reform because everybody treats the
pathologies and criminal justice as
something along the lines of a flu when
in fact it's a stage four cancer what
are the uh you know what are the types
of policy reforms that you know that
would take us from Advil to uh you know
an anti-cancer drug well one would be uh
we call it the trial Lottery and so what
we could do is we could take some random
sample of cases where a plea agreement
has been reached but not yet entered and
send those cases to trial just to see
what the outcome would be
um right now prosecutors will tell you
and judges seem to believe that
virtually everybody who pleads guilty is
in fact guilty and would have been
convicted have they gone to trial there
is a compelling empirical evidence to
suggest that's not true and most
criminal defense attorneys that I've
spoken with estimate that somewhere
between 20 and 50 percent of cases would
result in either an outright acquittal
or at least a hung jury if they went to
trial if we were to undertake that
simple experiment which we could do
tomorrow
um that would uh significantly undermine
uh both the the rationale and the
edifice of of the the what I've called
the The Plea driven system of mass
adjudication that is the very lifeblood
and motor oil of the American criminal
justice system and I think a lot of
things would just fall apart at that
point we would go back to having
constitutionally prescribed jury trials
as the default mechanism for
adjudicating charges and the landscape
would look completely differently among
other things the government wouldn't
have the resources to pursue as many
prosecutions as it does now and so it
would start leaving
um some people alone 80 percent of
arrests these days are for misdemeanors
12 million arrests a year 80 for
misdemeanors at the same time that we
have 50 of homicides go unsolved and
more than 50 of other violent crimes
what if the whole law enforcement
apparatus refocused itself on actual
criminals like murderers and armed
robbers and left people alone for things
like drug possession I think something
like what I just described could
actually be the key for getting to that
uh new realities can I ask very quickly
I mean part of the discourse on crime
and this you know is both totally
consistent with how we started this
conversation and drifting far afield but
um you know one of one of the arguments
about the decline and kind of social
order in cities uh places like DC New
York Philadelphia San Francisco L.A is
that you know the cops are now treating
many lower level crimes as as if they
don't matter shoplifting for instance
public vagrancy uh intoxication and
things like that how does that play into
your idea that what the cops really need
to be do is focusing on dangerous
criminals yeah so it's important not to
look at that in in you know sort of
through blinders right because because
police are not only unserious about
quality of life crimes like vagrancy
um and you know sort of public urination
and defecation they're unserious about
other crimes as well they don't want you
to think that but they are that's why we
have thousands of untested rape kits on
the shelves in many police departments
that's why nearly half of all murderers
go unsolved and so um the problem I
think is not that police have singled
out the subset of crimes to be unserious
about it's just a further signal that
they are unserious and and ill-equipped
uh for for enforcing laws that actually
uh protect the the fabric of Civil
Society most of the behavior that you
just described with the possible
exception of of shoplifting or at least
you know actual professional shoplifting
rings are probably better addressed
through other mechanisms than the
criminal justice system uh vagrancy
open-air drug use things like that
you're not going to stamp that out just
by uh increasing uh the aggressiveness
of um of enforcement and you know the
the I think we don't know for sure but I
think the facts tend to bear this out
you know Chessa boudain who's a
famous Progressive prosecutor in San
Francisco was ousted more than a year
ago and a Law and Order prosecutor was
put in his place and guess what violent
crime has gone up in San Francisco so
whatever the code is we haven't cracked
it but just uh throwing monikers around
and condemning people for being
Progressive prosecutors that's not
really where the action is the I think
the pathologies and the you know the the
the social uh disintegration goes much
deeper
um and look the criminal justice system
is not a Swiss army knife we use it like
one but it's not and it has a very
narrow and specific function or it
should
um and using it for anything and which
is by the way to to remove genuinely
anti-social people from society and
discourage others from behaving likewise
but to use it for all the things that we
use it for for issues of poverty and
mental illness uh and and substance
abuse Etc it's a it's a mismatch between
the tool which is only good for a couple
of things and the problems which are
Myriad um and we try to use the wrong
tool for all those problems so that's
why it's been a disaster in my
estimation before we turn it uh back to
Zach for uh final question can I just
very quickly Clark ask you what it
what's your theory of social change is
it
um you know because a lot of the work
that you do and a lot of the work that
Cato does and other people I mean it's
to bring uh you know kind of the the way
that things are to public light I mean
is the theory of social change that you
you uh unveil expose reveal how things
are and why they're bad and then the
people rise up and demand better you
know through elected officials through
social change things like that or is it
more of you you know what we really need
to do is to be speaking to people who
are Elite positions particularly in
political power economic power to change
the laws
um could you talk a little bit about
that as it relates particularly to
things like Criminal Justice Reform yeah
yeah I mean I I feel like I might be
about to step outside my Lane a little
bit I appreciate you indulging me uh but
let me just say like I I am not um
that's that's not my my thing I'm a
constitutional lawyer with a strong
interest in Criminal Justice Reform and
I will say this
um I do think that the evidence is quite
compelling um that that individuals who
grow up in what we used to call a broken
home so you know maybe a single somewhat
dysfunctional parent for example
um they only have access to to schools
that um you know clearly are not getting
the job done Etc they're prospects of of
kind of you know integrating into
society and being a productive member of
society uh are fairly low and so I think
ultimately the problem uh starts and
this may seem like a cliche but the
problem is at home
um children need to grow up in a loving
and supportive environment at home and
also within the context of a community
that has norms and that has healthy
Norms
um where they are inculcated into people
at a relatively early age and so they
don't steal not because they're afraid
of being punished they don't steal
because it's wrong for example uh and I
don't know how to accomplish that but my
gut is that if we don't fix that if we
don't create a situation where most
children grow up in a loving and
supportive home in a community that has
the right kind of norms that are
instilled at a young age everything else
is just a Band-Aid maybe I'm right maybe
I'm wrong that's my gut
to wrap this up uh let's talk about
Trump's how Trump is likely to fare and
what how he should fare ideally in this
criminal justice system that you've
described as pathological
um you know the this is a list of some
of the potential prison terms that he
could face the maximum term of
imprisonment 10 years 20 years 20 years
there is no mandatory minimum for of
imprisonment for any of these listed
charges
What You Know How likely is it that
Trump
will go to prison and as a follow-up
after that should Trump go to prison
well the most important thing to keep in
mind about that graphic that you just
showed is that no one not even justice
department prosecutors think that those
are appropriate punishments for those
crimes no one goes to prison for 20
years for for conspiracy to obstruct
Justice
um those are there in order to help
prosecutors coerce people into pleading
guilty so they're essentially trying to
jack up the possible Max punishment so
that they can offer you a generous
discount from there just to give you an
example you may recall the Varsity Blues
prosecution evolving the Hollywood
celebrities the
um the the standard plea offer in those
cases was two months and then they were
threatened that if they didn't take the
two-month plea offer then they would get
a superseding indictment that included a
conspiracy to commit fraud charge with a
20-year Max
um that's those those figures are just
there to coerce people into pleading
guilty that's the function they play in
our system and everybody knows it not
everybody admits it but everybody knows
it
um Trump has been treated with kid
gloves by and large so far in the system
and he'll continue to be treated with
kid gloves most uh defendants in his
position would not have been released
these pre-trial they would have been
locked up most federal defendants are
denied bail and locked up pre-trial
again largely for the unstated purpose
of making them more amenable to pleading
guilty but Trump was allowed to go on
his own recognizance he wasn't even
required to turn in any Firearms which
is standard
um or have any you know have to report
to a PO or anything like that so he's
been treated with kid gloves even if he
doesn't know it he will continue to be
treated with kid gloves throughout the
process
um he will get very careful attention
both at the trial court and the
Appellate Court level uh for any motion
that he makes and there will be a bunch
um and the judge in his case Eileen
Cannon whom he appointed that's not
there's nothing I mean that happens you
know whatever we never had a president
who's actually gone to trial in front of
a judge that he's appointed
um she actually has the power under rule
29 of the federal rules of criminal
procedure to Grant unequival at any time
in the case and if she does it after a
jury hasn't been in panel it will be
unreviewable and unappealable it will
stand now there's some chatter that the
Department of Justice might have
something in its back pocket which is
that Trump was not actually charged with
the misconduct that occurred in at
Bedminster in New Jersey when he was you
know handing around the document so
maybe they could get a second bite at
the Apple by bringing the charges there
the one thing I feel confident of is
that anybody who thinks they know how
this game is going to play out is a fool
and I would love to be on the other side
of that bet because there's a lot of
dynamics of play that have never been
seen before our system is uh is complex
both um as a sort of on paper but also
in terms of its Norms
um and there are just simply too many
possibilities um and too many Forks in
the road for anybody to predict how this
case is going to unfold except for I
would say two things Trump will continue
to be treated with kid gloves by the
Department of Justice and the Judiciary
um so that so that we Ordinary People
don't get a good look at what it looks
like when they really go after somebody
um and they really you know put the
boots to a defendant which is what they
do in most cases they want to preserve
the illusion that they wear the white
hats so they're not things like threaten
his family members which is perfectly
permissible trying to when they're
trying to reduce a plea threaten to
indict a family member happens all the
time and
um the second thing I think is is uh
entirely predictable is that this case
will not unfold the way that an ordinary
case would there are simply too many
twists and turns so but it'll be
incredibly entertaining incredibly
entertaining whether that's good or bad
I don't know but it's going to be a you
know uh on the level of sort of Greek
tragedy in terms of its uh cultural
significance I'm thinking it's more like
a mix of Arrested Development and Veep
at this point everything in politics is
veering into a a long-running series
maybe with a little bit of South Park
maybe a little bit hopefully one one can
help yeah do you think he can get a fair
jury trial like you know selecting I
don't even know what the process for
selecting a jury to put the president on
trial would look like
yeah um so yes and no I think you can
get um I think you can get people on the
jury who will in fact do their best to
to render an appropriate verdict in
other words they won't try to sneak on
knowing that they already have a strong
pre-conviction what he won't get is a
fair jury trial in the sense that um
juries today are carefully curated and
um the the courts and prosecutors go to
considerable lengths to exclude people
from juries who understand what we call
jury Independence which is the it
includes but is not limited to jury
nullification the idea for example that
you may acquit a factually guilty
defendant if for example you don't think
they should have been prosecuted for
that particular crime or the
circumstances or there's been some kind
of law enforcement abuse or for whatever
or if they're being threatened with
um a a massive trial penalty jury
Independence also includes things like
for example
um not um uh accepting uh you know as as
binding uh the judge's interpretation of
the law that's a relatively new uh
feature of of the American Jury process
and it's not something that goes back um
throughout Antiquity so will he get an
impartial jury in the sense that it may
include people who have some concept of
jury Independence no he will not because
those people are assiduously identified
and excluded from the process so that
instead what you end up with is a jury
of kind of trained circus seals um who
will embrace the false conception of of
the modern criminal jury as one that is
only permitted to engage in fact finding
and then apply those facts to the law as
given by the judge that is that is a
very new development in our system it's
it's a pathological development and it's
nothing like the role of the jury
throughout centuries of anglo-american
history but it's the one that
prosecutors and judges prefer because
those kinds of juries they would rather
a kind of Appliance an obedient jury
than one that thinks for itself so
that's the kind of jury uh Trump will
get not an independent jury but a a sort
of a circus seal jury but but in that
regard it's not like you'll be singled
out that's what every dependent gets in
the system so uh call it what you want
but um yes he can get what now put it
this way can he get what passes for a
fair trial by modern
last question what is the best outcome
for people like us who or people
watching this who care about limited
government care about rule of law care
about the Fidelity of our institutions
is it Trump ending up behind bars is it
some sort of uh plea deal being reached
him getting fined are there any good
outcomes here for those of us who care
about these things no but I think there
are
the the optimal outcome as far as I can
see is that Trump gets he gets a A
Sterile process as as is currently
available under existing Norms
um and it plays out and all of the
relevant actors including the
prosecutors the judge and Trump's
defense team play it straight and Trump
ends up uh convicted of at least some of
the charges if the evidence is as
powerful if the evidence in court turns
out to be as powerful as it looks like
it will be
um and then Trump you know I don't think
it would be helpful helpful to see him
go behind Barb but maybe he gets uh you
know uh confined to the squalid environs
of Mar-A-Lago for a year or something
like that and he has to wear an ankle
monitor and then you know you can just
recede Into Obscurity for the rest of
his life I think that's probably the
optimal outcome
Clark Neely thank you very much for
taking the time to speak with us today
and Nick thank you for joining as always
thank you to all who watched and we will
be back in a couple of weeks same time
Thursday 1 pm see you then